and
go okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i
have a special guest on the channel ally
oh hey how are you thanks for having me
on here i'm super excited you came on my
channel a couple of weeks ago but i just
had so much fun talking to you and i
thought that maybe the audience wouldn't
be about it because we do get so chipper
and intense and it is a lot of
high-pitched female voices but everyone
seems to enjoy when we t when we chat so
yeah i mean i think we got similar vibes
you know what i mean
[Laughter]
um before i start guys do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell while you're at it go
to ally's page and subscribe to her too
it's real thumb sapien
thank you yeah if i get to 2k subs i'm
gonna do a live q a with my fiance and
for some reason people are super
intrigued about our relationship because
i'm in an
age gap but i actually
love him i think he's amazing so people
are stunned that this is possible so if
you want to see that live q a happen
subscribe to the channel
yeah guys her her stuff is good she's
very entertaining and like she's got a
really good like head on her shoulders
like i really like that your stuff is
like
like sometimes you watch red pill stuff
and it's very much like doomsday you
know what i mean a little bit and you're
like very positive like you you frame
the wall in like a positive way like i
saw a piece of content um from you the
other day that was saying like you don't
have to look at the wall as a bad thing
it just means you know it's how you
structure your life
the wall is only a problem if you're in
denial about aging as a woman that's the
only the only time it's an issue or if
all of your content and character
is solely invested in your physique
that's when you struggle as a woman
every well-rounded woman i know isn't
really worried about the wall because
they're setting up their lives
accordingly for when they're going to be
40 50 60. and you know for any woman
that thinks that the wall doesn't exist
do you really think that your grandma is
as hot as she was at 18 like i just want
to know
yeah and um
no and i don't know why like it's okay
to have other things in life other than
looks like it's not the end-all be-all
it's just basically saying you're
getting gonna get less hot the older you
get which is like kind of a given
yeah and i think too that i'm a little
bit lucky that i wasn't born necessarily
a solid 9 or 10. and every time i say
this people want to come in like oh my
god you're so pretty no i've been to
miami okay i know what's up i know
what's up and so for me i think also i
was overweight for a long time i
actually lost 45 pounds so i think that
that helped me to keep a real level head
and not over invest in my looks but i'm
going to say the looks are important
don't get me wrong i'm just glad that i
don't have that everlasting genetic
makeup to where i'm going to be super
hot and attractive and maybe like a tad
delusional at 30 or 40 because i see
that happen a lot to very attractive
women
i see that too it's like their whole
value is based in their looks and they
don't really work on like developing
other skills like communication
being not not always not always but like
i see it a lot in super attractive
girls yeah and there's always that
argument not all women not all women i
get it we all know a tall asian but what
we really talk about is right we mostly
just talk about men and women on average
that that's it and unfortunately on
average men find women around age 23 24
to be the most attractive and on average
women in the west find men to be
attractive when they're
on average four years older than them so
these things they just exist we're not
making it up i wish we were making it up
but that is not the situation
yeah
so um let's talk about how you kind of
found the red pill
so you were married before right
yeah could you tell me about that a
little bit
yes so i was married for five years but
i i got married out of scarcity i got
married for stability
it i wish it was a beta bucks situation
i think you know what it was i had
gotten married off of potential because
i think deep down inside i knew that i
wanted to stay home with my kids i
wasn't sure how long i was going to stay
home but things had happened within that
marriage
once my spouse at the time got out of
the military where he got really regular
really quick and i started getting very
concerned because it was apparent to me
that i was going to be working for the
rest of my natural born life because
when you present a man with divorce and
then he's quick with it and starting to
change well he's only changing because
of what's on the line it would have been
nice if the things that i had said for
the past year and a half were taken
seriously then i wouldn't be in that
position but it was it was a real
learning experience for me and i ended
up finding out that i was attracted to
traditionally masculine men and i didn't
expect that because a lot of the women
that i was around growing up was born to
a lower socioeconomic status they just
tell you to marry a good stable guy they
don't say anything about that attraction
piece which is very important to me
yeah i don't know why we don't ever
really talk about like traditional
masculinity at all like it's almost
frowned upon it's what i found like if
you ever say i like a masculine man
it's always
like almost there's always push back
when i talk to like girls my age about
that anyways
well there's pushback but then look at
who they're dating it's like athletes
that are six foot tall you can just
smell the testosterone seeping off of
him from across the room so like what a
woman says she's attracted to versus who
she actually ends up dating is two very
different things but when you when you
use that same lens as women women
they don't understand so this is what i
keep hearing is that well
what men are attracted to is different
than what they say they're attracted to
but women are not understanding that who
a man will sleep with is going to be
different than who he will marry
two different types of chicks so as much
as i would love i would love the
attention from
dressing a lot more sexier maybe pushing
up my breasts maybe wearing smaller
clothes i would like that just because
it does make you feel a little bit good
and validated i'm just going to keep it
a stack okay
but
the the attention that i'm getting from
men isn't going to be the attention that
i want and i know every time that i
dress kind of skimpy i know that i have
to be like prepared for the nonsense
that's going to come my way because i'm
athletic so i'll go out and my sports
bra and my tights if i'm just on the
move on the move i don't have time to do
a bathroom and change i get everything i
need done in a day but i know that
that's going to put me in a position to
be cat called and i actually actually
don't like that that much so i try not
to do that
but yeah i mean
even though i'm on the the boring side
of things the housewife side of things i
just have to remember that all i need to
worry about is if my man at home is
attracted to me i don't need the world
looking at me per se although it does
feel good
that's so that's very honest right
that's what i love about ali she's very
honest
um okay so you ended up getting divorced
from the first guy and then how did you
meet your now husband so i knew him i
knew him the whole time i was married
and this is what throws people off
because it comes into like well the beta
orbiter maybe she was seeing somebody on
the side wasn't anything like that
because my fiance is very rigid if if
anybody met him in real life for five
minutes they would know just how rigid
this dude is so he outranked me and my
spouse at the time so we never
socialized
out of the office which would be the
military we were both in the military he
was an officer i was enlisted you're not
supposed to hang out and also in the
military too
it's like perception is reality so if
you're hanging out with a hot little
young honey people are going to think
things about you people are going to
assume things and you're going to get
some heat at work because of that whole
well like is the man abusing this power
kind of thing also infidelity's rampant
it's illegal to be unfaithful in the
military i don't know if people know
that you can actually write it at work
yeah yeah you can get a write-up at work
if you cheat on your spouse as the
service member so people don't like to
take those kinds of risks i see people
cheat on deployment though
um so i used to work for him he was a
medical provider he was always very kind
to me and he wasn't condescending and i
liked that because you make a certain
rank and these guys just have really
huge heads we always treated me like a
person and i always learned from him so
when my divorce rolled around i had i
maintained a friendship with him
after i got out of the military so i get
out of the military i get divorced and
all of a sudden he looked like a snack
so we just built a friendship and i know
i know how that looks but like life is
not black and white and it happens like
monkey branching happens whether i knew
i was doing it or not if that's how i
was going to look and i i don't mind
because like i i'm the one in the
relationship am i really gonna care what
these people are thinking when i'm 60.
like i got the man of my dreams it
happens
no that's that you are so cute like the
way you talk about him is literally and
i can tell he like really supports what
you're doing too
oh yeah
and so you okay so now now you're
engaged i thought you were married today
i got that wrong but you're engaged
right do you have a wedding date yet
so
things politically are very interesting
right now for the military so i actually
don't know if i'm going to get married
when i think i'm supposed to be getting
married if it's going to happen much
sooner than that
um so basically we're just waiting on
paperwork because we're getting a prenup
and as much as people say well
does he really need it
listen if my man
is feeling any type of anxiety related
to me being with him for the finances
and all i have to do to ease that
anxiety is going to be signing a piece
of paper
that's my business also validating my
man like not the end of the world not
the end of the world so
that's pretty much
all that all that's in the way from
getting married but to be honest there's
not gonna be much of a difference in us
getting married
in reality legally there's gonna be a
lot of changes but in reality we're
already living together it's gonna be
the same
yeah that's i've never had a issue with
a prenup i don't know why people get
emotional about it because if your plan
is to stay married then what does it
matter
yeah that's what i said so i follow this
lady on instagram at take the love pill
she really breaks down femininity and
masculinity and
because of women's hypergamous nature a
prenup is not necessarily a bad thing
because you get the resources if you
stay
but you also get resources if you if you
try to leave and it's actually very hard
to have an airtight prenup but as a
woman you can put things in there to
advocate for yourself your prenup
doesn't just have to be about his
security it can be about your security i
can't get into details about mine but
there's things that happen after five
years 10 years stuff like that
financially on my part and people would
say well if you're a woman and you get
married you're just supposed to stay
married and if you leave then you get
nothing i don't think anybody ever plans
for the death of a child and very few
people's marriages can survive that so i
mean i think we're just doing what is
sensible
well and uh if a guy loves you he's not
gonna want to leave you high and dry
like even donovan on his channel he said
like if me and devin don't work out like
i would financially help her the rest of
her life
like like guys don't want to just leave
you like they're not these evil men that
just want to
okay yeah i i i know you're all good i
know probably having some wild people up
in her up in her apartment
i thought somebody knocked on my door
and it scared me but i think it was just
the storm
you know when you when you do that it
looks like a horror movie like if
somebody's just about to like come in
and snatch you
sorry
no it's all good um in any case
yeah if a man loves you he does not want
to leave you high and dry you really
think so like
i like to believe that my fiance is not
a sociopath but every woman has ever
been killed by one didn't know okay i'm
i am betting my money statistically
speaking that he's not a sociopath it
would crush him if he just left me and i
was homeless on the street or something
you know but that's all based out of
fear because women are coming women come
to me and they tell me that i'm taking a
risk by financially depending on my
fiance because we're not married but if
you know enough about the family courts
and common law marriage he's assuming a
lot of risk but women don't know that
because we're sort of pedestalized
everything is sort of
um we're we're the ones that are we're
having our time wasted couldn't be that
i'm possibly wasting his time nobody
nobody thinks about that they just think
about the automatic assumption is that
men are bad or we're trying to take
advantage of us
well and what could you talk a little
more about that because i actually did
not know that he assumes risk by having
you like live there and financially
depend on him so yeah talk more about oh
man
oh girl okay okay so i'll tell you i'll
tell you um
right so
when you want to look at the possibility
of what can happen in the united states
you want to look at the uk and the uk is
much more woke than what we have in the
u.s
so you can live with a man for a few
months
and in some instances there have been
rulings that
that constituted a common law marriage
so basically the man is cohabitating
with his girlfriend
they break up
she instead of breaking up initiates a
divorce do you see
and each state what they have that
indicates a common law marriage will
vary so in the state of kansas which
shout out to the midwest that's where i
live way too much of gluten in this air
so here
if you call each other husband and wife
and you're not legally married or you
didn't do a church ceremony that
constitutes common-law marriage
so you actually have to be careful about
the words that you call each other how
you have your big accounts linked and
for what
i get so worried about this information
ending up in the hands of a gold digger
i get so worried but i'll just i will be
transparent if you have a man
directly paying for a large bill for you
like let's say it's a car payment maybe
it's car insurance maybe it's rent so
the bill is in your name
but the payment is coming from his bank
account with his name
that can be enough for a woman to ask
for a common law divorce whether you've
been together for six months maybe
you've been together for several years
so it varies
yeah so it's like people like oh my god
you're taking so much risk like yeah my
eggs but i'm 27. like
i do want to have a baby as soon as
possible though so
well and it's not like you're doing
nothing like you're building a business
right now like you're getting the
opportunity to build like the business
that you want
oh yeah i'm so tired of these horror
stories like people out here really
looking at the color purple and thinking
that it's everybody's relationship or
waiting to exhale i mean i don't know i
don't know if you know i mean i'm a
little bit more ethnic for those of you
that don't know i'm puerto rican but i
also grew up in a
yeah my stepfather was black so i i got
the best of both cultures really so it's
just like these terrible horror stories
about what if a man takes advantage of
you nobody talks about what happens if
you're cherished like let me tell you
this so i just started this femininity
journey because i
just wan i'm very much a try it out see
if it helps you kind of girl and i tried
it out because i wanted to be becky
housewife i'm not going to front i
wanted that and so i had to do research
and i tried it out for two weeks and i
was getting a lot of responses from him
positive feedback so positive feedback
gives you that positive reinforcement so
i just kind of kept doing it but he
started opening doors for me all the
time
every time like
all the time the door's getting open
left and right he's always making sure i
have water baby are you thirsty stuff
like that so you know all these
nightmare stories just tell me you
picked the wrong dude without telling me
you picked the wrong
well it makes it
it makes you look bad because you're the
one who chose him but and and here's the
thing they don't talk about like men are
so willing to help you like my brothers
i could talk like on and on about how
how many times they've just like helped
me with random situations in my life
that's why i could never hate that
because my brothers are like literally
like when covet first happened i was
supposed to run a marathon
and it got cancelled and my older
brother austin i was in i'd moved to
milwaukee and didn't know anyone right
he he has all his friends run with me
and he organizes like the whole trail so
i can like run it the whole and it was
just so nice i'd even ask him to it's
just like stuff like that like men are
so willing to help you if you're you
know nice to them and a pleasant person
to be around
yeah yeah it's true like
learning how to work with men and just
be grateful for their assistance will do
wonders for you professionally as well
it's not just
for you know keeping your man happy
things like that although that's what
works for me and i look i get it like
not every woman wants to be
the kind of housewife that i want to be
i understand that maybe they want to
work maybe they want to have a career
that's fulfilling look
i'm just here to help women who want to
get married and stay married i look at
traditionalism as insurance but in
regards to men just being helpful for
you
i would say that
a lot of my professors is predominantly
male and i'm establishing better working
relationships with them all the time
just because i do say that i'm grateful
for masculinity and it's interesting
because the more i talk to them about
energetic dynamics they don't really
they don't really disagree with me they
pretty much agree that women like
resources not one of these masculine
professors because they be like
masculine in the closet or something i
don't know they're all ripped but yeah
it's it's a good thing to
try out and see if it works for you as a
woman actually i'm curious if you agree
with this i i say it's not necessarily
about the money okay
like if a guy won the lottery if he's
broke wins the lottery i don't think he
becomes hot it's about the skills he
like acquires in getting money like his
work ethic his drive um usually comes
with some sort of competence would you
agree with that or disagree
no i 100 agree i get i get presented
that point a lot
so
to that i normally say that what gets
forgotten and all this red pill stuff
because it's money muscles game frame
okay true
but these blue collar men they're very
hot there's nothing sexier than if your
man fixes your sink without calling the
plumber you know what i mean oh my gosh
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
is your man resourceful
that's all women need yeah it's like you
i think jordan peterson says it's
usefulness
like across the board that's what women
are attracted to
um okay so you you're starting a
business now like this is your channel
and everything can you talk a little
more about that you
you're helping women right
yes well women that want women that want
to get married like i said i don't think
dating works at all i've looked at the
modern dating scene
it's it there's no
need for any sort of delayed
gratification and marriage only works
with delayed gratification what i think
happens is that a ready-made husband
shows up and bumps into a ready-made
wife these two people individually have
already decided i'd like to be a husband
one day i'd like to be wife one day and
then bam they meet in real life and
that's it um
so my
thing is i'm trying to help children but
to help children you have to get to the
women
that's really who my target audience is
behind the scenes so i try to help women
to be well-rounded so that i can prevent
things like fatherless homes like child
abuse and i think that it it is
effective and it works um because i've
seen interventions when they intervene
in the mother's life then the children
turn out better i think so these are
things that you can look up i think
richard trembley he talks about
mitigating aggression for young children
but a lot of what i see that are
complaints in the dating market in
regard to women
modern women is really pathological
women and it's my
suspicion
that a lot of these women are
pathological because they were brought
up with maternal narcissism so for me
it's all this like big picture
connecting the dogs and trying to get to
these women before society crumbles
that's where i'm at well and it's it's
tough okay because we're in a different
like birth control changed everything
everything like because i i always say
if you take away the consequences in a
society people do more of the wrong
thing because there's no consequence
right
and
that's kind of what birth control did
right like it gave women the ability to
sleep around and so more women did
um
and and delay very much worse than that
too yes okay so so yeah go ahead
no we're too agreeable you gotta finish
your statement
no that was pretty much it like it
delays like it used to be my mom got
married at 21. the average age of first
marriage is like 28 and 31 in the uk
yeah it's it's insane so basically
whether women believe it or not i think
they're naturally red pilled we will buy
and do anything that tells us that we're
young for as long as possible because a
lot of our worth is what we're born with
which would be fertility which obviously
as you age that sort of goes down so
things that make you think you're
younger longer than you actually are
birth control is one postponing marriage
is one pursuing a career is another one
so we we kind of like do these things
but
you will get old one day so i try to
tell women in their 20s don't plan for
your life based off of the options that
you have now like think about how you
want to live at 60 do you want a man to
be there or not some women 100 like
they're definitely okay with the
independent women but i i try to look at
the happy independent women that are
actually out there doing their phd
research they feel like their time on
this earth was valuable but
the independent woman i'd be seeing is
like these fake small business ceos and
ceos nothing it's no publicly traded
company they're working at the dmv
trying to tell me i'm making a mistake
by dependent on my man now get out of
here
oh my god that's so true
they're so angry and i know that oh man
i could get into it you know i worked at
a couple store for a year
bro so a couple stores really code for
working at a sex shop i was actually
ignoring i just wanted to see what was
up when i tell you that every single one
of us on staff is pathological in one
way or another i'm not playing like all
of us were messed up in some way shape
or form so when you're looking at these
women that are working regular smegular
jobs yeah i'm suspicious
wait so what do you mean you were messed
up like because you said you had some
sort of transformation i think i saw
that on your story once
yeah yeah um okay so
so long story short
i grew up in a lower socioeconomic
status and i grew up with a lot of risk
factors being a single mother home
meaning that
i was physically assaulted for about a
decade just at my upbringing and i i
didn't know that was going on until i
was about 23. so it was very quirky
which is just code for i had complex
ptsd and i had no idea but
no man wants to marry you or have babies
with you when you're freaking out all
the time and crying all the time and
just absolutely terrified about living
life so
i first i had to get some type of
diagnosis and then after that i got
cognitive processing therapy which is
you kind of think through your triggers
there's multiple different forms of
therapy that you can seek for ptsd which
i don't even really like that it's
called ptsd because that's how you're
supposed to respond when you're being
physically assaulted because you're
supposed to kind of be concerned and
free down a little bit yeah um
but that helped me a lot to chill out so
that i could stop misinterpreting my
partner being assertive in having
boundaries as something much worse
wow is that common like a common issue
amongst people that have like gone
through physically abusive situations
i think i think most
let me how can i wear this i think most
people that have been
a b usc
they don't know
very few people ever find out so these
are the women that you're seeing that
are pathological out there on the dating
market they have no idea that they have
these severe cognitive distortions so it
it takes a long time for people to get
treatment for ptsd to be honest because
it's usually small they start having
some issues at work start having some
issues in relationships and then all of
a sudden it's like oh like you got fired
you're an alcoholic now you're twice
divorced on your way it just it
eventually you hit some type of point
where okay like let me go see your
professional or you just end up homeless
or an addict i mean pick your poison
so you felt like or
what was most effective for you was you
said
cognitive behavior sorry you got to say
that again no no it's okay cognitive
processing therapy okay so
you
i'm a very a thinker a critical thinker
and a bit of a way and i don't well i'm
not trying to elevate myself it's just
i've been asking some very big questions
for a very long time like adults did not
like me as a child it's very curious oh
me either
i know exactly yeah okay i know you know
you know because you're you're asking
your aunt why are you going on another
date with him if you don't like him and
you're literally eight years old and
they're staring at you like no you
didn't i'm like yes i did what's the
answer so anyway
i asked i asked why my trainer was
overweight at like
[Laughter]
why would
sorry keep going keep going no no it's
it's so funny it's so funny so um okay
okay where are we at where are we at
cognitive
oh condom processing therapy okay okay
cognitive behavioral therapy exists but
it's for anyone you can be traumatized
and have cognitive behavioral therapy
you can have this anxiety depression or
you could just be a regular person let's
say you don't have baseline pathologies
group in a very secure situation
um you can
get cognitive behavioral therapy just to
be a more well-rounded person that's for
everybody but cognitive processing
therapy is more so
for uh people that have been traumatized
because trauma does rewire your brain
there's everybody knows that at this
point so what you do is you go through
the the more traumatic memories so
complex ptsd like it's so disputed i'm
not even sure that it's really a thing
like they try so hard to define things
that they can't define like how about i
was just i had my life thrown into
multiple instances let's just go from
there so you you pick
the more traumatic memories and you go
through them and it's things like
when you're a kid sometimes you think
something bad happens to you because
you're bad but really
when you're a kid and an adult chooses
to physically assault you
that is on them they're making the
choice to hurt you there might be
reasons for that but you typically as a
child there's nothing you could have
done to change that but you think that
as the victim and it stays with you even
into adulthood well maybe if i had just
behaved a little bit better so you end
up coming to this adulthood just
thinking that you're a bad person who
can't do anything right so i went
through this cognitive processing
therapy broke things down added some
logic and i was able to really assume a
lot less responsibility for the things
that happened to me and uh that that
helped me to date because i was very at
risk of being childless and alone just
because i was like freaking out all the
time over nothing yeah
so what advice do you have for like
young women
um who want to get married
think about it in your 20s don't wait
until you're 30. and i don't mean that
just because of the wall because if you
take care of yourself as a woman
you should still look pretty damn good
at 30. audrey hepburn look amazing at
30. i could i could just name so many
women that are attractive at 30 although
your fertility does go down by the age
the problem is more so if you make it to
30 being single you probably picked up
some bad habits along the way and
they're really hard to undo at the same
time i think when women get married very
young so that's kind of what i did when
they get married very young they might
not know themselves because i got
married when i was 20 and when i was 25
i was a completely different person and
i was attracted to different kind of
things it was just all the way different
so think about it in your 20s if you
want to get your career lined up because
let's be real a two income household
goes a lot further sometimes than a one
angle one income household
get you can get your career done by 24.
and i'm not kidding you can be 16 to 18
you get yourself in um
like a dual enrollment program in high
school so you graduate with your
associate's degree or maybe you decide
to serve in the military four years it
done you got a gi bill and you get into
a stem degree you just you can have your
career set up halfway if not fully by
age 24 and then you can go out there and
pick any duty you want because i get
women want to know if we can actually
make things happen for ourselves and you
can most definitely accomplished nursing
school by the age of 24. you can
accomplish being um possibly i think if
you're really a hard charger being a
physician's assistant by the age 24. so
you get your career out of the way your
apartment's nice your bills are paid and
guess what you got access to some higher
quality men because people ask me how do
you meet high value myths work for them
be a dental hygienist like come on
anyway
i didn't think about that maybe i should
have gone to dental
hygiene
you know because everyone makes fun of
um they make fun of the secretary that
mary's a doctor but who really have in
the last laugh is like that chick up in
her five-bedroom house
oh my gosh wait so that was actually
going to be my next question what is
your advice for like what what
your clients what type of men do you
advise that they go for
high value high value only
i titled this how to find high value man
but it is clickbait i'm sorry guys
oh yeah i did that one of my videos too
high value man is a little bit a little
bit
a little bit subjective in a way and not
in a way i get it i'm not trying to be a
social constructivist up in here it's
just
the a woman who is with a plumber who is
making 80 000 a year who is very
influential and fit she could think he's
a high value man i think all that
matters is like is your man have value
to you you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah yeah
yeah so
what the problem that i run into with my
clients is that they don't know that
their lists are so
picky okay they are very disillusioned
with what a man really is and what i
mean is
they ask for what sounds i ideal right
so like i want him to be funny i want
him to be intelligent i want him to be
ambitious i want him to be fit i want
him to make typically six figures
they're not saying six figures they just
say that they want to have kids
and they want to be emotionally
intelligent and
yeah so they think that that's not a lot
i'm telling you right now that's a damn
unicorn because you have to make some
confidence oh what do they want to they
want that he's young so if you if you
look at my relationship there's
definitely compromises that i made but i
i find that to be okay so for example
one of the compromises i made is he's
twice my age
yeah age you know like tell me that's
not a compromise now granted i don't
really get along much with millennial
men um but that's because they have like
a masculinity crisis and i'm not i'm not
going to teach you how to be a man like
i'm trying to have a lumberjack so
um i tell them to date based off of
three values because
values is what's going to make a
marriage work be versus preferences a
preference is that he's six foot tall
that he's funny that he's emotionally
intelligent like what if the man
who is going to hold you down for the
rest of your life and is a good person
maybe he comes from baggage maybe he's
got mama issues maybe
he
had some things come up in his life so
he never got to reach his absolute full
professional potential things like one
of his parents got cancer so he had to
drop out of school or something like you
just never know so pick a guy off of
three values three values that i could
say that i would have for myself
is that i i do want a man that is fit
okay that that's just i'm sorry can't
can't cap on that and i want a man who
is going to be
doesn't need to be emotionally
intelligent but is just willing to be
able to sit there with me in my feelings
like don't need the input just need to
know that he's going to be able to
tolerate when i'm emotional and the
other piece is that he's gonna be able
to provide enough for me to be able to
stay home and raise small children do i
plan on working with my children older
yes so those are these are things that i
value when really it's like providing
for the for the children like that's
just valuing family
and
emotional compatibility
and izzy sexy so three values that's it
that's all you need you don't need this
list of 10 10 20 30 items i used to
think that these red pill dudes were
tripping until i started working with
women and i found out they were they
were telling the truth really oh my gosh
i just started doing one-on-one sessions
with people i've only had men sign up
but
i would
i don't know do i want do i want to work
with women is it
not how can i do this so i work with
women because i want to make i want to
help well-rounded women and because i
didn't have any guidance um
on what it means to be a woman who who
has the
ability to have optimal mates election
which is that's what i was trying to do
so i i don't really coach women for
profit the only reason why i charge
women is because sometimes in order for
somebody to do the work they have to pay
for it because if you do things for free
people just can't see the value i can't
tell you because at the very beginning i
would help women and give them advice
for free but i was realizing it was
taking like two three hours out of my
day to help these women that they don't
really want to help themselves so when
you set a price it's a it's a bar of
energy yeah
yeah yeah so they have a little bit of
skin in the game and even then like
sometimes they're just not committed so
i i say that i i coach women to learn
more about empathy it's not necessarily
profitable most likely the most money
i'm gonna be making is off of youtube if
i wanted to make money with women i
would tell them what feels good right
all the most successful femininity
coaches that i know they're they are
they're like they have the stuff to back
it up for example married 18 years
well-rounded children but
in reality the ones that i see that hit
it big
they don't even have the relationship to
co-sign
and and so it's like you're getting
advice from women who have been single
for 20-30 years they can tell you how to
get a man but most of them can't tell
you how to keep a man oh my gosh i then
never settle
like what what do you mean never settle
who are you looking for like the perfect
like
like
you can't settle a little bit like not
even
it's crazy
so you had that girl that said that she
wanted a 200 000 engagement ring oh my
god i did you see my face when she said
that i was like
ma'am from who
from
and this is a crazy thing
my my brothers
my younger brother just out of college
guarantee he'll be making six figures in
five years hardest worker ever met older
brother
makes six figures my dad
multi-millionaire i'm like okay
lady don't you want to ask me
like i know these men that like make
this money i'm like none of them if
they're if they're any of their fiances
or like my dad you know my mom said can
i have a 200 000 engagement ring you
know what that none of them would get
the guy
none of them would spend that
girl no check it out if you know what it
is it's people that haven't been around
money so they don't know how money works
so you
your father is a top half of one percent
earner so you know
that even though he makes as much money
as he does he didn't buy no no 100 000
200 000 ring that's the thing women
think when it comes to a high value man
he's going to send me on trips to buy
i'm going to have a gucci bag like honey
i was getting a dress at goodwill last
week the only way the high value man
keeps the money is if you know how to
how to not waste it well and it's a
value because men who value family like
my dad my whole life he said i just want
to pay for my kids college i was stuck
in debt for like 10 years i don't like
is he va that's where all of that was
like his life's goal was to pay for all
of our colleges it wasn't
you know pay for my mom to do nothing
all the time and that's that's the thing
if you marry a hard worker
he's going to expect you to work whether
it's at the house with the kids like you
you are not going to be doing nothing i
guarantee that oh i'm telling you yeah
so like as fun as youtube is i mean
really i just what i wanted to do i'm an
experimenter like i said before so i
wanted to see like what's up with this
algorithm can i really figure this out
turns out i can turns out i can but now
that i've committed myself to the
internet i kind of got to stay here but
my fiance let's say i didn't want to do
youtube
i would probably be running marathons
because that's just who i am i want to
do something with my free time i don't
care if i'm sitting here making making
knickknacks for my house i'm going to do
something so you can't just sit at home
and twiddle your thumbs and then a lot
of women too it's amazing how they get
uh overwhelmed with housewife work
like we got air fryers and we got
roombas and we got windex like imagine
having to clean windows before windex
was on the scene like i am not trying to
hear these women
oh my god this is what i was saying i'm
like can we return our rights like can
we
can we can we give them back because
i'm like guys everything's automated now
we fumbled a bag like we could have just
you know
wong says
that feminism was one of the worst
things to ever happen to women because
it's like we told we told men the secret
that we can do everything that they can
do and i was in the military that job
straight up beat me into femininity i
got i got a stress fracture on my femur
like that is yeah
girl i'm totally up from the flow up so
you can be an independent woman if you
want let me let me know how it goes sis
let me know
um let's talk about age gap dating
i
i had never heard
of anyone push age gap dating okay like
before i was i remember being like 22 23
and going on a date with 30 year old
being like
kind of old
and i wish i had thought about that
sooner because it seems like a lot of
the problem is like girls and guys
dating
at the same age because the girl is like
i want to get married and the guy is
like give me another decade you know
and it seems like a lot of girls like
kind of waste their youth a little bit
on that would you agree or disagree
they we we do a little bit but i i think
because i i've had baby rabies for a
long time because i
i knew i wanted to be a mom when i saw
my little brother being born and i was
13. so i was just always like i want to
have kids now okay um
so we get caught up in a little bit of
that that feminine imperative to
reproduce
the only reason
i did not intend on being an age gap you
see what i'm saying it is true that my
relationship is an outlier most women
that are my age don't want to be with
men that are 23 years their senior year
i happen to
sort of like i said make that compromise
because he's very cool very smooth also
still very hot i don't think he actually
looks his age every time i put a picture
of him people say that he's looking like
he's in his 40s maybe his late 30s
so there's there's reasons why i ended
up with him but
my issue
more so is that millennial men and gen z
men
they're very feminized i can't i have to
take care of them and you know what i
say too this is it's going to rub people
the wrong way it's going to rub mental
the wrong way um
i don't really encourage women to date
men that come from single mother homes
it's a problem because they pedestalize
their mothers and they pedestalize their
mothers they pedestalize you and then
there's this thing there's this concept
of emotional incest that goes on with
maternal narcissism so to explain
it's the woman can never get a man
but you know she's able to have a baby
that that happens a lot
but the son ends up being the father in
a way he he's who she goes to for her
emotions for her validation they almost
have a boyfriend girlfriend kind of
situation
and it happens a lot more than people
think so that that is something that i
notice is an issue and when you go
younger you increase the likelihood that
that man is coming from a single mother
home do i want these things to change
absolutely but i i am telling you the
worst thing you want is a bad mother the
last thing you want is a bad
mother-in-law to deal with and see every
thanksgiving and every christmas
and you know when we talk about this
stuff like there's always exceptions to
the rule right like ben carson came from
a single mother home but like in general
i agree i think it's really important
for people to have had a model of what
marriage looks like
and i think it's it makes it harder if
you haven't right but that's not to say
there's not exceptions but
i don't know i think it rubs people the
wrong way
but i don't know why we always have to
say like there's exceptions to the role
you know what i mean
so that's because it's i feel like it's
obvious yeah it's a cope right so here's
here's the thing is
if you're an above average person
sometimes you don't even really notice
so
i i really i don't like to toot my own
horn i don't like to say i'm above
average but i also work out three times
a week and i run long distance sometimes
a six mile sometimes it's three
let's let's give myself the smallest
amount of credit possible let's say i
ran 30 minutes
three times a week
majority of americans are sitting on
their couch oh yeah
yeah most people don't even make it to
the gym so exceptions are for
exceptional people so oftentimes the
person that's talking about an exception
is an average person and i don't mean
that to be disrespectful i think average
is important average makes a little turn
i think average women need to start
seeing the value in average men because
i sure do every time my car breaks down
i'm like where you average boys at where
you at needs your help and that's why i
cannot stand women that hate men because
who who do you call to fix your car
who who do you call to like do any i'm
in london now i'm in a different country
than my family i miss my brother so much
there's been so many times where i'm
like oh my god
i cannot like fix something or do
something i'm like i i need med and i
don't understand why that's
controversial if i put something on my
tick tock just talking about how much i
like appreciate like the men in my life
and there were so many girls that
commented being like it must be nice for
you you're next like you know
i'm like why
do we have this hatred for fifty percent
of the population it doesn't make sense
it's usually i'm going to speak from a
point where i grew up in a lower
associate i grew up in the hood okay i'm
gonna just be point blank period yeah i
had air force ones go to the bearings
and i think big pun is still really
great also i think job rule is the bomb
so
when you grow up in those situations
they
they make you afraid of men because
there's this misconception
of
the good alpha the whole sum alpha to be
alpha you have to be honorable so i
don't know if you've read the rational
mail yet i'm having such a fun time with
it highly recommend highly recommend but
in there he talks about how there's good
alphas and bad alphas so the way i break
it down
is that you got prison alphas and you
got portfolio alphas but prison alpha is
still still going to be hot he's jacked
he's rip and he quite literally would
kill another man for you and that would
be helpful
probably 200 years ago not very helpful
right now so a lot of women coming from
my culture
they end up with the prison alpha and
the prison alpha does not come through
he's a horrible father and they
basically tell you as a young girl you
cannot trust men do not ever depend on a
man go to school or join the military
and they don't even talk to you about
positive
mate selection because they don't even
have experience with it like gen x knows
nothing about the dating scene right now
so don't even go to your mom for any
type of dating advice unless you're
pearl's mom pearl's mom knows something
so that's where it's coming from they
get these prison alphas and surprise and
they get burned
yeah or you know he has kids with like
two other women that he doesn't take
care of and
you know
i know it i don't i don't know why women
think that they're gonna be the one to
change it but i suppose oxytocin is a
hell of a drug i'll say that well i
think
yeah that's very true like women get
attached we do and that's
yeah women get attached i've
definitely been there where i've been
like attached and
i like should have left sooner than i
did
um
okay so
um age gap dating 23 years the i always
say my ideal is like 15 or less but i'm
not opposed if the guy like if he's
attractive and fun i don't really care
about the age you know what i mean
yeah yeah i agree and something so i get
presented with these two things all the
time um
well one he's so much older than you
when i
am let me think when i am 50 he will be
73.
so
and nobody cares about the age gap then
that's one thing but by then like i've
hit the wall and
to be honest
people are like aren't you worried about
him passing away on you i mean he could
i don't i don't only only god knows but
i am more concerned about your average
35 year old man having a heart attack
than my man i'm gonna tell you that
right now dude is ripped no your
husband's
sorry fiance i keep
i forget i always because you just seem
like married like i know you're not but
you seem married so i keep thinking that
you are
i know i know i get it i get it um but
you were saying
um he he's like he's jacked he's in
great shape
oh oh abs most definitely and that that
i don't know if he meant to do it he you
know he was blue pilled in beta for a
long time he was he wasn't ripped he was
still attractive he's got good genes but
he would just let women run up on him so
i i guess
he was a blue-pilled alpha briefly where
he
tried to make college work and ended up
joining the military all this other
stuff he ends up getting on the military
going back to school at 30. but he got
super ripped super raped so that that
was
a a situation for him where he started
to gain a lot of confidence when it came
to women because he was getting chased
left and right so i think that's part of
it but um back to the age gap thing too
like literally every day i wake up
and i look at my phone and it's like
some miserable woman on the internet
trying to remind me that my man is gonna
die or something and it's like news
flash i i roll over next to him and i
know that he has wrinkles like i know
you're not you're not telling me any new
data but for me it's it's come down to a
quality versus quantity situation
because i could date a millennial man i
could date a gen z man but i really
enjoy the quality of my relationship and
if that means that i have an amazing
experience for myself i love that i
think that i can make last and i'm i'm
okay with the compromise like i get hit
by a truck tomorrow like i hope not yeah
but you know people don't know what
they're talking about it's just
projection of fear so many women are
afraid you ever notice that it's always
the ones without profile pictures like
making comments i'm like where let me
see you
you ever sometimes i respond and i tell
them come on my channel like we'll talk
about it come on
pull up
they know they never accept they never
accept it's crazy
yeah
you're right that it is always these
people anonymous and it's even men too
and i think
i think the red pill just gets so
muddied up by people that
haven't done the research which i ended
up doing the research kind of on
accident i was an egalitarian but i was
fed up with female behavior and i would
confide to my fiance about the things
that i was frustrated with or that women
are capable of malice because i'd been
primarily bullied by women my whole life
and so he ends up like putting me on
this red pill you know the the
documentary it basically lays out that
women are just as capable as aggression
as as men but um
really i didn't know that
yeah we just do it differently yeah okay
no tell me more i haven't seen the
documentary
okay okay so if you look up the fbi
statistics on dv it's almost 50 50 like
men and women okay right so
women have a tendency to slap more
though
versus like physical assault that was
something i read in a social psychology
textbook but
also women's
typical choice of aggression is indirect
aggression so it's um attacking
somebody's character or
what what is it when people have esteem
for you what is that called i can't it's
coming out of my brain right now like
character reputation okay
yeah yeah okay yeah so that's that's
indirect aggression and that's why
you'll see like some women do you know
false accusations about certain things
but women are just as aggressive as men
and then when you look at the statistics
for child abuse
women are doing it too so that was one
thing that really woke me up that women
do have some
negative aspects to them but it's not
it's not that female nature is good or
bad it's just human nature is what it is
and we're all capable of violence so
that was more so what i was trying to
figure out is
you know
what's wrong with me that i can't
maintain female friendships and come to
find out that i think there's quite a
there's a lot more pathological women
than we really know is the conclusion
that i came to
um
but i wanted to say that when people
look at my relationship and they see the
age gaps they literally think it is the
pinnacle
of the red pill experience they're like
oh my god he got a younger woman he's 50
he has money
uh and that is such a unicorn fantasy
and i'm 27 now but you know one day i'm
gonna be 37 like these looks only last
for so long
no and that's
it's not about the money we've said it
before and again it is not about the
money alone it is about
the character that is like built in
order to acquire money i would say
um unless you're a straight-up gold
digger which i can very much tell you or
not so
oh i mean who knows i could get a tumor
and hyper me could just ruin my life i
might just steal this dude's r8 who
knows catch me on the news
really quick really quick uh ladies
thank you for telling the nude truth i
found you two on donovan and i'm glad i
did keep telling the hard truths thank
you so much for the donation all
donations go towards new mics for um and
a new sound board so i can host eight
girls in my living room for a podcast
that we're gonna do weekly is supposed
to be today sadly there was a storm so
next week we're gonna we're gonna
do it but thank you ninja watcher for
life okay sorry
no i i'm all about this um yeah i know
when we get to talking we just kind of
kind of can't stop
um but i also i also don't want to over
talk you on your own platform and make
sure you see stuff i don't oh no i am
that's like when i invite people i want
you guys to talk
you openly say you are hypergamous
yeah like what's wrong with it what what
i'm supposed to do be with a dude that
makes forty thousand dollars a year and
raise my three kids like with what i
need
well i think everyone even men too they
everyone wants to get the best mate they
can like on both ends like i don't think
anyone's saying i hope i can find
someone that i
can do better than i think men are just
the problem is when it gets unrealistic
and i think that's where men get mad
when women like won't settle won't
compromise but
i don't see anything wrong with wanting
to be with the best like fit for you
right so hypergamy gets a bad reputation
because women right now we have
unfettered hypergamy like the
we like stuff you don't think
hypergamy's real do me a favor after the
livestream go to the mall look around i
want you to count as many female humans
that you see and why you count as many
male humans as you see tell me we ain't
out here shopping it's true go to
goodwill go to ross
it's full of chicks so we we just like
stuff
is my my perspective on it and also it
for the women that don't think that
hypergamy is real how come every time
one of your home girls graduates from
law school or medical school the first
thing they buy is a gucci bag or some
louboutins like
it's very obvious for hypergamous
it's such a waste of money too i could
you will not catch me you will not catch
me buying oh no
you will not catch me buying that
it's it's a lot of fun too because i was
hanging out with my grandma
last week which a couple days ago and we
were out shopping
and she's literally trying to buy her
11th perfume and she doesn't need it and
she's just grabbing the stuff out like
oh this is so cute and it's it's female
nature in action hypergamy isn't bad
it's just it's
it can get you burned and that's why i
say women don't settle with men because
that is disingenuous to the value of men
really what you do is you take a deal
and you take a deal that makes sense the
man offers you his resources you offer
him this in return you make an agreement
you abide by the agreement and
everything is good and kosher
the reason why women are hypocrites you
already know some a lot of this stuff
but i guess maybe your audience might
not know is uh we have a globalized
dating market if i wanted to
want right now
i could find a millionaire across the
world who would fly me out the thing is
is that the same guy that's going to
commit to me so let's say
i lose my hypergamous mind and i just
leave my man for another man who makes
way more money maybe i decide to play
that stupid game because it's dumb
the the man that i'm running into who i
guess we would say like high value or
something
he is going to know that i'm a woman and
incapable of commitment and capable of
judgment so he's probably not going to
reproduce with me he probably most
likely will not marry me
right so you just have to know when to
take a deal with someone and
we were saying earlier it's not
necessarily about the money so my man
could lose his job but i'm not worried
because i'm very confident that within
30 days he would find some other form of
gainful employment and we can downsize
right i'm not expecting him to become
this homeless heroin addict overnight or
something it's just let's just keep it
normal
oh no it's it's the same thing my dad he
right before in 2007 2006 he bought a
neighborhood with their life savings
and then the housing market crashed
so they put everything all of the money
they'd made and they were not as like
well-off as they are like now back then
like their business wasn't even doing
close to as good and like my mom didn't
leave him because he was you know
i don't want to say he was broke because
we still lived in the same house but
like we were very close to losing
everything
and
uh like men value loyalty like they want
someone that's going to stick with them
through thick and thin
yo it's crazy it's crazy what a man will
put up with for some loyalty
like
you know my relationship looks really
good on the internet but i'm still a
woman i'm still emotional and i'm
telling you sometimes the way i just be
absolutely in my feelings crying on the
couch over something small like i'm a
loser
you know and he's just sitting there
taking it saying it's okay it's all
right there they are i can't do that at
work ain't no manager or supervisor
gonna hold me down but a man will sit
there and listen to your crazy rant for
30 minutes
just because you're there you're solid
about nothing about mountains
about everything
i saw this commercial that just it was
the kid like
um thank you for the super chat i be
ripping them um i really i'm not
i don't know why you had to put that as
the description i'm gonna just
keep going
i mean if you if you have to spend two
dollars to validate your existence on
this world then you know like fine
because it's just going to end up in
pearl's pocket so
thank you
oh my gosh what do you think of west elm
caleb also if you guys have topics put
them in the chat that was one but before
i do ladies looks will get you in the
door but character is what will make him
retain you i agree it can't it's not all
but
my man has been with finer women i'm not
gonna friend i
i don't have the discipline for abs i
would be straight up like women think
they want to be with a millionaire with
a billionaire go ahead do assist let me
know if you have what it takes to be a
formula one race car model because i
like to eat
but um you were talking about this west
elm dude what's that
you don't know what west elm caleb is
i think that's the guy that was just
ghosting a bunch of women on tinder
wasn't it yeah
yo and isn't it funny how women tried to
make him look bad for ghosting them even
though it's just the most hypergamous
thing i've ever seen in the world like
they out here trying to make him look
like he's a bad man but they're the ones
that slit in the dms like get out of
here
women do it all the time
you acting like none of you girls have
ghosted a guy like come on come on
yo and women don't even have dignity
they will tell you oh yeah like i'll
meet you there in an hour and the dude
be sitting there and you don't even say
anything and like i so here's my thing
yo torsha if you're watching i need your
opinion on this one is like is that a
power play or are they actually that shy
i i don't i don't know what would
possess someone to do that because it's
too easy to just
i'm not coming and then block him like
what is what's going on there what's
wrong
do what
the girls like go to the place and like
leave
no no so the guy goes to the date at the
time in the place that the woman said
that they wanted to go and then they
don't say anything and they don't show
up
oh my god i would never do that that's
that's such that's so shitty oh my god
that's so shitty
but they're definitely doing it and i've
met some some of my girlfriends that
have done it and i'm like that was you
like why why are you like this but
they're always the hottest ones that
don't know that they're hot in my
opinion well you can you can text it
takes two seconds to text him and cancel
you could cancel it an hour before at
least he won't show up and be like
waiting
it's sad it's sad and the guys that get
depressed too i met this guy who was
beta very effeminate
like i i don't know what's going on with
his testosterone but he just he didn't
have it in the music california native
but he was talking about
he was talking about how he drove an
hour to go see this girl and he was
there at the restaurant and then she
canceled on him after he was there now
that i know a lot about the red pill
he probably was shooting way above his
league but women have a lot of leverage
it's not
it's not that uncommon for me to see the
sexual market value disparity to where
the man is much more attractive than the
hippopotamus he with i've i've seen it
if you tell that
i'm sorry i'm a call of duty
this is what i like about you you're
very honest
i can't i don't i was talking about this
the other day if anyone calls me thick
i'm offended because everyone that they
call thick is just fat it is not thick
you are overweight okay
you know what it is too you're very
you're very you have a lot of muscle on
your legs
right but
it's it's uncommon i don't know because
for me when i work out i don't really
get that like definition i see it in a
couple women that do crossfit so you
must have been in the gym doing some
type of weight training but i don't
think men are used to seeing that
because i've only i've seen it on
on one girlfriend who is a power lifter
i've seen it on you and i've seen it at
a few with a few chicks at the cross
vision so it's i don't think it's normal
it's very no it's very common in
volleyball it's like a volleyball body
yeah because we've been jumping we've
been jumping like five days a week since
we were like 12.
like i can't i can't i can deadlift
close to 300 pounds i can squat like 250
like i
i can i have strong legs you kind of
need it for the sport that i'm in
but
oh my gosh i
no i know i'm in shape i play semi-pro
volleyball but like like i just i don't
understand why why why don't we just say
it like these girls are overweight but
why do we call them like thick beautiful
like oh well i'm not saying like i'm not
saying you're dead ugly just because
you're overweight like i've met very
attractive girls but
you're still you're still overweight and
it's okay weight can change you can lose
weight that is the one thing we can
change
yeah i don't know what that's about
because at the end of the day it's a
woman that suffers from the delusion
because she ends up being the one that
ends up having a cardiac episode that's
why i'm very much that body positivities
just go in the trash i say
shape positivity not size positivity
what we're trying to say is that if
you're a woman in your hourglass or a
pear or a rectangle that it's okay that
you're just a natural woman and that's
true because we don't typically see
natural female bodies publicizing even
these victoria's secret models i did a
whole video about
how we are conditioned to hate our
bodies as women but
it's because the fitness models that we
see it's shocking to us and also we want
to look at their stuff that's one thing
and that's how the algorithm works is
off of what's going to get you taken and
responsive but the women that they see
that are athletic and i know this
because i'm athletic they have at at
most an 18 body fat percentage
and a lot of these fitness women their
goal is not to be fertile their goal is
to be sexy because they end up coming to
find out that they don't have enough fat
for the hormones in their body now
everyone just took that argument and
applied it to everything but nobody
talks about the women that are
emotionally eating which is a problem
that i had i didn't know
um i didn't know it was fat in high
school i had no idea and my mom was just
like feeding me which it's a little bit
of a cultural issue because growing up
what did i hear every time my plate was
full and i wanted to throw it away that
children were starving in africa so
i
i was
behind in the dating market by my own
mama like she was trying to set me back
and she didn't even know but
women and body image and food is just so
conflated i'm actually gonna have
an
a medically obese woman on my channel
okay guys be cool um but she's a
critical thinker and she says all the
time that this body positivity thing
it's all bs and she's always showing
weight loss journeys on her channel so
i'm gonna be excited to hear her
perspective that's a collab i have in
the works for for march um
yeah it's just nonsense and there's no
male body positivity no no or short like
short kings like you know what i mean
like short like short men positive like
they can't change that but we can at
least lose weight
well here's
this is the sad thing too is short men
so it comes down to nutrition there's a
difference between wasting and stunting
so stunting would mean that you don't
get to reach your full height because of
nutrition but let's say that you're an
immigrant from two generations ago your
your peoples were starving right because
the the egg that made
let me think the egg that made you was
in your grandmother okay so like think
about the conditions that your
grandmother was in so a lot of these
guys that are short it's most definitely
not their fault in fact it is just
coming down to nutritional scarcity
so they definitely can't change anything
about it but those things can improve
over time
and what i think this is why i think
women are a tad a tad bit ungrateful
you'll see some chick who's like four
foot 11 that wants a six foot guy
like come on girl because all we really
want is the dude to be a little bit
taller like why do you need the giant if
you're a [ __ ]
why do you need you are you're preaching
to the choir as a tall
because female that's the hard part okay
i am just
i wish i was attracted to guys shorter
than me but i just i'm really if it's a
little bit like it's fine but i'm really
not attracted to guys a lot shorter than
me
and it it makes it a lot harder in
dating because the pool you're dating
from is like so much more competitive
and i was thinking if i was five five
like i wouldn't care i would it would
just be like five seven five eight
that's fine
but why why six i keep hearing these
girls that are like five five they're
like six four i'm like six four
leave me like
you know what's funny myron gains from
fresh and fit he's like six foot four
and i i went over there and i saw him
standing and i was like
much taller than i expected
what was i thinking oh so i actually
made a decision a long time ago to stop
pursuing men that were six feet tall
as crazy as that sounds i just got the
vibe from all these six foot tall men
and this is when i was
around i think 18.
i just found the guys that were five
eight that they loved me the most and
they were the last the least arrogant
because these six foot dudes they have
all these women hollering at them so i
wasn't really it wasn't special to them
i was like forget that i'm just gonna go
shorter
you know what i found okay the six four
six three guys they prefer women that
are like five five five seven ish
this the guys i've met that are like six
six to six seven they always really like
tall girls that's what i found
which you would you wouldn't think
there'd be a lot but because i'm like an
athlete we're like surrounded by you
know taller people but that's that's
what i found with men in dating i don't
know if i'm right or wrong but
i think you might be right i met my
first tall couple a couple of weeks ago
they were anarcho-capitalists which i
thought was like super cool but
the dude was mad tall i was like how's
the weather up there and then his wife
was tall too and they had giant girl
babies so their daughter was three but
she looked straight up six or seven
which
they're winning some type of genetic
lottery over there like that that
family's gonna survive the hard times
like uh short people we don't have
business
no short people live longer
yeah we do yeah you do um no the
tallest couple i know the girl i played
volleyball with her in high school she's
six five
and she's dating a guy that's six ten so
it's funny because their wedding
pictures that she doesn't even look as
tall as she is
yeah i mean i'm always whenever i meet a
tall woman i'm always shocked but i feel
i kind of feel bad for them because i
know it's got to be weird being the tall
girl
from everything that i've i've read and
seen and what is it this uh
there's a show i think called tall girl
is that a thing
yeah okay yeah it's like i love i love
being tall i wouldn't change my height
for the world i love it except in dating
that is the only complaint i have like i
feel like i can reach things i like
people like look at me when i walk in i
don't mind like
you know but
it's just it's just the dating thing
makes it a little bit harder a little
bit
oh oh definitely but you know you know
what what i think how how i think you're
going to end up being okay in this
dating market which you know don't get
caught up in who who a man will sleep
sleep with versus who he'll marry
because i know that for for good girls
it's a little bit intimidating but i
think you're okay with competing i think
what yeah is the wholesome chad which i
have a wholesome chat he happens to be
twice my age a lot of women don't like
that but these wholesome chats exist
i'll be out here in the midwest there's
these guys they're like yeah i want to
build my girl a house i want to you know
bring up bring home i want to chop wood
create a fire i wanna deliver my own
babies like there are guys out there
like that it's just usually no i'm not
i'm not too worried about it to be
honest um sometimes my comment section
says i should be but
we'll see i'm not i'm not super worried
i think i'll be okay
no i think you're at this crossroads
where you are being presented the
opportunity to do something that you'll
never get to do again in your lifetime
but to be
to be completely clear you're not a
stranger to networking and your parents
are very familiar with networking so i
don't think you're going to have a
problem running into a male prospect i
think you're going to i worry a lot less
about a woman like you who like you've
seen your mom and you don't think that
she's stupid i run into women that are
in their late 30s and they're still not
getting it they're not getting that they
have to put in a contribution to the
relationship to get something out of it
oh my gosh i am
i told my parents they could pick up my
husband i was like when i get back from
europe you guys can have it sorted out
for me
because i
i want
someone my parents like you know that's
like really important to me actually
you know um you were asking questions
you wanted to talk about how to find
high value men this is really
interesting because the only reason i
found out how to find high value men is
just
hanging out with my man hanging out with
him whenever we go on vacation because i
wasn't out here you know husband hunting
he just outranked me and he was hot
yeah so
when we would go on vacation he's got
some very specific male interests and
he's a little bit on the bougie side
i'll say that my man will wear a suit in
the hot sun at a park and i'd be looking
at him like baby you were you were
overdressed but that's who he is that's
who he is i think if it wasn't who he
was it would look a little bit weird but
it's just he's always wearing some type
of blazer um but if you want to find
high value men and do not give this
information to gold diggers if you're a
gold digger and you use this information
i hope i hope that your judgment day
comes so
they are at cigar lounges wealthy men
like cigars i've had i had one nice
cigar once because i asked them if they
had any that tasted like a starbucks
latte and they did
but in general that's where you're going
to find wealthy men you'll find them
they wealthy men like they like whiskey
they like cigars
and you want to go to like a nice city
for this probably vacation spots again
keep in mind the higher up in value you
go the less likely the guy is to commit
so
you have you do have to use some type of
discernment as a woman okay you're
either going to be the side chick or the
wife you got to make a choice
um
other places that high value men are so
not at
bars
but in
bars that are in restaurants by the
water
to own a boat you have to have money
right yeah go to your nearest lake
and you can go to a nice restaurant you
don't want to go somewhere where
what what is it where the the main
dishes and things like that they're less
than 15 bucks that's not the plan here
other places you can meet high value men
is if they're if they have religious
convictions you can meet them at church
but you're going to have to sift through
a lot of betas in that situation
and the last place that i think you can
meet them is oh oh well coffee shops
they like to read books there and then
wine lounges but typically
if an older man is at a wine lounge now
it's possible he's a wine connoisseur
but it could also be that he knows that
that's where the hot chicks are the hot
refined chicks so they do
you look for them there
parks working out you find them at gyms
and i think that's about that's about it
aside from working for them
huh
these are actually things i've never
thought about but i'm like i haven't
really started dating too much because i
just got out of a relationship but i'm
i'm starting to we'll see we'll see
oh yeah i'm pumped to see what dating
decisions do you make it's all you know
what sucks though is that you do have
this online platform
so it's no matter who you date it's
going to be all eyes on you and that
that is something that i don't i don't
like i don't really like putting my
relationship out there too much i try to
have my man as scarcely as scarce on my
platform as possible because i've seen
so many relationships end just from
having an online presence well i was in
a very public relationship before and i
i can definitely see like the negatives
of that um because
the comment section like i remember the
first time my ex-boyfriend like post
like we posted some a video together
this was before we were even dating
right the whole comment section it like
got millions of views right because
he the whole comment section was
basically saying how i was a downgrade
from the last girl he dated like the
whole entire comment section
and i you know what i mean i wasn't even
dating him at that point like we just
like were both in tic-tac made a video
together but
you know it's not a fun way to like
start is everyone talking about how
you're less attractive and you know you
say don't let it get to you but when
a hot like when it got a million views
and like
20 000 people liked that comment you're
like
damn you know what i mean
yeah yeah i understand exactly
what you're talking about
because we say don't think about it
don't talk about it but even donovan he
doesn't read his kind of comment section
you're not supposed to know how a
thousand people feel about you
evolutionarily that's just not what
we're prepared to do and i get caught up
in my comment section too a little bit
but i'm telling you it's always a
projection it's always a man the man who
wishes he could be that hot fit older
dude with the audi r8 and the 27 year
old wishes it could be him it's always
the woman that wishes she could stay
home it's always a woman who wishes she
could at least at a minimum just just
keep a guy
the things that we go through are
threatening and you have to you have to
think too like there's a lot of reasons
for women to be envious because like
let's say your dating life absolutely
flops i'm pretty sure your family is not
going to leave you high and dry so
people just get very jealous of the
things that they don't have or will
never have and also it's
i i mean i understand where i stand in
the sexual market value and i don't have
a problem with it without any makeup on
i you know i'm probably going to say i'm
a just i'm an adjustable six because
everybody says that they're a seven so i
don't think i'm allowed to say that i'm
a seven so okay adjustable six no makeup
nothing um
now if i get dolled up maybe i could
look like an eight or ten but
you're like familiar where you stand on
the sexual market value situation right
oh yeah yeah yeah i give myself a five i
think like when i'm dolled up i'm like a
six or seven
but like nothing when i look like
homeless yeah i give myself a five
yeah
yeah it's okay
well
here's the thing
is that men know that very hot women
come with problems
very privileged sometimes they don't
have personalities i have seen the
unicorn a time or two who is wholesome
and hot actually my girlfriend she's
wholesome and hot yeah
i know a couple unicorns too yeah
yeah so for people that just show up in
your comments section they may throw
numbers at you
you and i are very
probably the most realistic women i've
seen in a long time i don't want to to
earth horns or nothing but not telling
me nothing new by letting me know that i
don't look like a race car model i can
turn on the tv and see that so yeah and
what is it why is it an insult
like i don't you're still above average
and like like the average woman is 150
and five five or one 160 five five so
i'm like look
even because i think they just talk
about like facial symmetry right so
that's that's what they're talking about
when they say like rank yourself one to
ten
but
even like your body factors into it so
if you're just not overweight
like
you're still above average i mean it's
not you know it's not a fun you know
thing that most women are overweight
right that's not
a fun reality we live in but like
it literally makes us above average
and don't get wrong i you know of course
i wish i was more beautiful i really do
i think it would really help my youtube
channel to take off a lot quicker and
things like that but i i say these
things to my fiance you know i'm keeping
a stack so what he always tells me
is that eleanor roosevelt
one of the few quoted regrets that she
had was that she had not been born
prettier because she she is
she was like the obviously first lady
but also very much an independent woman
was running things as well so
she had professional success but even
though that she was the first lady to
one of the most powerful men in the
world she still wished that she had been
born prettier so that's just that's
normal that's normal i'm not going to
feel bad about it
okay high value men make under 10 of the
population so good luck finding me okay
i thought you men don't comment on
youtube channels because they're busy
working so
plus you ain't got a picture it's a
picture of thanos
oh i'm going to hell i'm sorry
as i said it's clickbait guys it's all
about what the woman values i've said
before and again i would marry a coach i
i need the work ethic and i need him to
be
you know useful and smart but if he's in
a career that like musician coach
doesn't make a lot of money i am cool
with that i just
i don't
need your money respectfully fives make
great wives thank you i'm gonna make a
very good wife oh two dollars navigating
church girls is harder than normal girls
what do you think about that are you in
a church
yeah well i i have this problem where i
tend to have a higher iq than the pastor
like no disrespect okay but i don't know
if you guys have figured it out yet but
i am above average intelligence i can
oftentimes
test circles around your average men
because average i don't know if you know
about the average iq but they are closer
to mental disability than they are to
genius so
anyway so i ended up leaving my church
because i just i couldn't take the dude
seriously anymore no offense but
the problem with church girls is
they're
they're either
too good like way too christian and
people say that you can't be that but
you don't want to be so heavenly minded
that you're of no earthly use kevin
samuels that's a quote from him and on
the other side is that they're christian
but you know part-time how women make
rules for alphas well no they make rules
for betas and break rules for alphas so
it's like i'm saving myself for marriage
but then i ran into a bad boy last
semester and he took my b card but i
promise some christian is like no no we
need we need some consistency but i
think it is gonna be hard for men
because um
i i find them
to not understand why a man would be
cautious to approaching marriage they
really think that what they see growing
up in a two-parent christian household
is how it is for everyone out there
and it's oftentimes
not or um
or they still kind of end up in that
that beta male situation too that that's
who they end up in a relationship with
and not knowing why they end up getting
divorced about a decade later so i think
it's i would agree that it's got to be
harder vetting a christian girl but i
think it's hard hard vetting uh women
period yeah for sure
well and i
i made a video called the rational male
brewing church for me because once i saw
like i watched his like broadcast on
like i haven't read his but i'm not a
reader i'm not gonna i'm a listener i'm
a youtuber
um but i listened to his whole broadcast
that he did on like church and religion
and once i saw it i couldn't unsee it i
realized i'm like they had this girl go
to my high school this girl go to my
high school
and tell everyone yeah i got rant
through
but don't worry
you can do that and still find a nice
christian guy who will love you it
didn't they didn't talk about how it was
because she was hot
you know what i'm like you get away with
more when and i'm not saying it's
impossible but like
and the other problem that they don't
talk about is like there's not a lot of
men in the church so they'll say only
date within your church but there's
three guy girls for every one guy
yeah they did a matchmaking thing at my
church and it was like 85 percent women
that signed up and how are you gonna say
that all these people like people can
only date in their church i'm like guys
even if you include all christian
churches i guarantee it's similar i i
guarantee
oh i i definitely agree and they're also
very paranoid about sex the men and
women that are in their church too
you know you have to accept human nature
and you have to accept free will there's
sort of this attempt to try to be
perfect it's almost as if they're
unwilling to recognize that jesus died
for our sins like we don't we don't have
to pay the price because he did
but another compromise that i made in my
relationship is that my fiance is not
christian
but what do i what do i often hear you
need to be equally yolked mind your
business
oh my god that's such bad advice that is
such
my dad is
he's he's not religious okay he grew up
catholic but like we probably would
never have gone to church if it wasn't
for my mom right
and i'm like my dad acts like a
christian and we have like more than
anyone like he doesn't have social media
he doesn't drink he spends his life
working for his kids you're gonna tell
me because he wasn't as as yoked as my
mom that she should have passed up on
this guy i'm like that's bad advice
i know it i know it and there's also a
denial too in in the church
about
well okay i think if you end up in a
legit christian church you'll see an
appreciation for masculinity but i i
heard one time now this was coming from
black men where a man was going to a
church and the pastor got up and said i
you men out here need to make honest
honest women out of these single mothers
something to that accord or need to make
honest women out of these out of these
women in church and in that church most
of the women were single mothers and
then the next day that a bunch of dudes
just never went back back to the church
so there's just
it's it's weird like the church is
feminized there are a ton of bait is out
there i'm just gonna keep it a stack so
i think the dating market's hard for
literally everyone the best advice i
could give somebody is to just
do
do something one percent better than the
day before
and keep doing that over 100 days and
what do you look at that 100 better at
something if you just kind of stay on
the self-improvement path you're going
to increase your quality and you'll run
into a quality person i didn't know
when i was fat in high school and with a
low self-esteem
it didn't enter my mind until like a
couple of months ago that the men that i
was coming across were probably low
quality men because i was a low quality
person so losing 45 pounds running long
distance taking hybrids changing my
major to something that i'm actually
passionate about
that has helped me a lot i mean
i did make the move on my fiance but if
i wasn't a worthwhile woman you have to
think that these men that make some type
of money right they're smart enough to
make the money so they're also smart
enough not to get played hopefully
hopefully
so just be willing to improve yourself
and compete and if you want to be
average
that's okay but just accept it you know
just see yourself for who you are i mean
don't don't live an average life and get
you know baffled by the results
it's like
like it's like a lot of people do it and
they're perfectly happy there's nothing
wrong with it
there's nothing wrong with living like a
middle-class lifestyle and you know
saving 20 to 30 of your income for
retirement there's nothing wrong
and so and so many women act like
they're above it but they're
they're literally not
yeah yeah so the amount of money that my
man makes annually
would not be enough for
most women most women that are 18 to 24
they would say that he makes too little
which is hysterical to me because i was
able to quit my job so
i would i would say that he making just
just enough fam just
and it's not it's not always about money
it's your spending habits
so i mean he's had what 20 extra years
to say i'm sure he's been wise with his
money if you're staying home
oh oh yeah well it's it's investing so
he didn't have children and he didn't
get married and you know when you when
you look at that so not all of these
guys end up that age in single
for no reason right so everyone comes
into the situation with a little bit of
baggage so you know like don't ever
think that my relationship is absolutely
perfect and we don't have our flaws
because i'm the first one to say that i
have flaws and he's also the first one
to say that he has flaws but yes i was
very fortunate that he was able to
not have any alimony not have any child
support i got him pretty much almost a
blank slate when it comes to
reproduction and resources
oh yeah
well thank you so much for coming on the
channel today can you tell them where
they can find you
yes so you can find me on youtube at
real film sapien you can find me on ig
real from sapien i have a blog
realtimesapien.com that one's that was a
lot of fun that's more the best way you
can get into my psychology
yeah guys go follow her her channels
because to be honest
one of the most fun people i've seen in
red pill like honestly she's very very
level-headed and very entertaining to
watch so
[Laughter]
also do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
if you've watched two or more of my
lives and you don't subscribe okay we
have beef
like like for real beef okay
all right thank you so much and i will
oh and thank you for the 20
dk i don't know what that means but love
the interviews
thank you so much five dollar super chat
delay gratification is what most people
lack these days and this is why a lot of
people don't succeed thank you go
subscribe to her stuff i will talk to
you guys next time
bye